more and more refugees are arriving at
chemical station in southeastern poland
there are plenty of children and elderly
people but hardly any men
the ukrainian government has banned them
from leaving
urging them to join the war instead
sergey skiba wants to do just that
he's a ukrainian reservist living in
poland who wants to go back to defend
his country
so as the refugees head west he's trying
to go east
it pains me here
i can't just watch while there's a war
in my country
i have to go there
when i watch tv it pains me here
there's chaos at the train station
one train just arrived from a leave in
ukraine
the trip usually lasts one hour and 50
minutes
but now it can take more than a day
the train drivers have to keep stopping
while repairs are made to the tracks
which have been damaged by the war
people are exhausted
including anna aralda from the vive
region
it's difficult
we're very grateful to the polish people
for helping ukraine
the queues at passport control are long
this is a european union external border
in front of the station volunteers are
doing everything they can to help those
arriving
offering free transport and
accommodation
most people here are outraged about
putin's war in ukraine
they want to do anything they can to
help
and simply show a little human kindness
oleg small is going to drive several
people to his home in krakow about three
hours west
there they can stay with him and at a
friend's house the 26 year old is
himself ukrainian
i've got two places free he says
my whole family is in ukraine
father mother my brothers and their
wives and children
they all stayed there
they're in the view
it's not a good situation but we're
trying to do what we can to help people
on this side
many ukrainians here are glad to be out
of the country away from war
but reserve soldier sergey skiba remains
determined to go to the ukrainian
capital
back in 2014 he took part in
demonstrations on maiden square against
the pro-russian government that was in
power at the time
i was at home and i saw 200 students
being beaten up by the police
that's how it all began
i felt so bad about that
that's why i joined the revolution
because i felt sorry for my country
[Music]
in krakow where oleg small has now
arrived with his car full of refugees
there's a pro-ukraine demonstration
taking place on the market square
but oleg is keen to get back on the road
to pick up more people from the station
at chemical
and maybe he too will end up going back
to ukraine
i think if my brothers take up arms i
will definitely drive over there
i want to stand shoulder to shoulder
with them
[Music]
the chaos at the border station has not
subsided
sergey is still hoping to get a train
heading east
but there are currently no trains going
to the ukrainian capital
as the city is under fire
his girlfriend who is at home in the
small polish city of bidgush keeps
contacting him she's understandably
worried
she asked me where i was going what was
happening
i told her that there are no trains and
so i will wait
she asked me to go back to bogyosh but i
said i couldn't go
as news comes in that kiev is under
attack he says that he will do
everything he can to get there so he can
help defend the city